foreign
hour for starting we'll get through our
work session underway and I see we have
unhl represented here if you'd like to
join us and discuss the two items that
are
I won't say pending on under
consideration
gentlemen we have a such we have a work
session going on
please
and I need a clerk
fun times
please
I thank you very much for having us back
this morning uh as a reminder I'm Jim
Dean president of unh and interim
Chancellor of usnh and this is Kathy
provencher who am I think you all know
our Chief Financial Officer and chief
administrative officer for the system uh
I know you're looking to wrap up today
so we'll try to be brief okay first I
understand that you voted yesterday to
fund the governor's recommendation for
the interoperability lab in the
blockchain quality assurance project and
we thank you for that as you've heard
that seed project will allow us to stand
up a crucial new function in a growing
business sector that will serve our
state and our business Community well
uh importantly I expect it will also be
a critical Workforce pipeline into that
emerging industry so thank you again for
that
um there are then two outstanding items
relative to the university system the
five million dollar differential between
our budget request and the governor's
proposal in fiscal 25 and then the
spending from Surplus for the Whitmore
Center
we understand this is pencil sharpening
time for you I don't know if you all
actually use pencils that's a figure so
you do actually
I was well done sir
yeah it's not the pencil it's the Eraser
that's important right this time of year
fair enough we know that feeling after
doing the same thing for the last
several years at the University and I
wanted to share just a couple thoughts
that might be helpful first relative to
the black Grant request we believe that
with an additional two million dollars
in fiscal 25 a week in guarantee today
that we can keep tuition Frozen for
in-state students through fiscal 26. so
that would be flat tuition for six years
and counting for inflation and and I
want to say this really carefully
because it's not a cut it's a 14
difference between what tuition would be
if we kept up with inflation versus what
we would actually be charging by keeping
tuition flat for that period of time and
that would be so the governor uh cut
five million dollars from what we had
requested and were asking to restore to
and with that two million dollars we can
guarantee two more years of flat tuition
for in-state students which would I
think be very helpful for them and and
actually we're starting to see the
results already from having kept tuition
flat first for several years already
other states and state universities have
continued to raise their rates ours are
staying flat and so that's helping us
competitively to keep more students in
New Hampshire which you'll remember from
our previous talk is really what this is
all about uh what would we give up on
sacrificing the additional three million
dollars some additional Partnerships uh
additional positions relative to our
Business Partnership work these are
important but we'll figure it out
somehow how to get that done but the the
additional two million dollars would
help us really substantially in terms of
tuition and I don't know that we've ever
in the history been able to keep tuition
flat for this long especially in an
inflationary environment so it's
something we're really committed to and
we appreciate your partnership in
helping us to do that
second topic then is the Whittemore
Center and as we mentioned uh when we
were here before for the project to move
forward we do need a one-time investment
from the state as you know this is one
of the largest venues in New Hampshire
and it's really a state asset as we saw
during the pandemic when we were proud
to host this this very body in the
whittlemore center so it's great that
you've all or at least if you were in
office then have all been there
um this item has been framed around UNH
men's and women's hockey and certainly
they would be the beneficiaries but I
wanted to let you know that there's
certainly other groups uh who use the
Woodmore Center
one is high school teams and so we host
the high school championship for hockey
and the whittlemore center and so that's
important to them there's not that many
places that could host them and then
also I'm not sure how familiar you are
with Northeast passage which is our
adaptive Sports organization that's part
of unh
and our sled hockey team which
represents New Hampshire actually has
been enormously successful we've sent
athletes to the Paralympics virtually
every time that they've been there we've
won a few times and part of the project
would actually be to allow people who
have certain handicaps to be able to
participate in hockey and play in the
Whitmore as well so that's something
that we're really committed to so as you
know it's a 30 million dollar project
UNH has already begun investing and we
have a number of private donors lined up
to support but basically they have told
us unless there's some State support
that they're not going to be able to do
this because we can't UNH can't cover
the difference so we had requested uh
eight million dollars and the governor
put eight million dollars in his budget
uh again back to the sharpening the
pencils and the and the erasers we think
that with a six million dollar
investment we can still hold on to the
donors uh that we will be able to figure
out the additional two million dollars
they'll be able to raise their
commitment
um and we'll be able to get the project
done what will we give up to go from
eight million dollars to six million
dollars basically nothing other than we
would be asking donors to come up with
the additional two million dollars and
that would allow us to complete the
project as anticipated
so thank you once again for listening
thank you for having us back I know that
I can feel it actually it's the first
time I've been here on this part of the
season I can feel the uh Edge for lack
of a better word that's a good word
and so uh for you to give us an
opportunity to talk with you again about
our needs we really really do appreciate
and we would be happy to answer any
questions that you might have
questions for them yes Mr chair
um in light of the time and the day I
would like to make a motion that we um
accept the request for two million
dollars and we also approve the request
for six million dollars for the
Whittemore Center I had a lengthy
conversation last night with um my Kiki
I don't know if he's a trustee or one of
your people
um and he talked about the importance of
that the state providing some kind of a
match so that people see that the state
is investing in this that in that manner
they can really go out and obtain more
funding so I think it's really important
we haven't always been good to UNH and I
think this is an opportunity to do that
and I would like to make that motion
please okay you have a second second
so the comment
just a quick comment um
at this point in time I'm uh willing to
approve the two but not the six if the
motion is made on both of them I'm gonna
have to say no on both of them I would
appreciate if the motion would be split
so I can vote accordingly also depending
on how things are developing through the
end of the day and where other funds can
be found I'm not ruling out the six but
right now at this point of the day I
could not approve it and
Mr chair I'll divide motion okay so this
is just on the six but the million for
the two million
um as requested to keep tuition down and
then the Six Million for the Whittemore
Center
two motions two motions
for the Six Million for Whitmore Center
all in favor
one two three four five six six to two
okay
now the two million now the two million
that we didn't spend in the Whittemore
Center and we're going to allocate
somewhere else
good pencil sharpening
you have a second for that motion okay
all those in favor
okay eight to zip those two go through
now we had some other items and I'm
I'm a little confused when we got onto
page three
there was a couple of items here having
to do with
um
the other universities
I think that was the two million that
was the two million okay okay
good
I'd just like to say uh thank you very
much for the support division two we'll
have immense impact on the University
system if it makes its way through the
process thank you and your alumni are
strong and calling
because I got a call last night from a
gentleman class of 73. you know
good
thank you all very much we appreciate it
we know you're busy thank you who was
the other no vote on the uh
I need to write it down was it Mr Beano
okay
no we just gave them back
yeah
that's right I guess I guess after two
minutes
thank you Mr chair um could I ask Mickey
to update us given the two recent votes
where we are in terms of uh bottom line
because yesterday for every item that we
approved we were trying to find matching
savings and right now we uh just
approved 8 million and I would like to
see where the
Source you know where we are on the
bottom line and then decide what action
may be needed so since that eight was
already accounted for since it was in in
the governor's budget that came we
essentially repurposed two of that so
it's a net zero those actions you just
took thank you
if I may ask Nikki uh now this
possible we took was on the uh Plymouth
State and King state
the instead of five we're doing two
million correct so that would be the
line 53 on your document there okay
right thank you
we have a an amendment uh 150 000 for
why don't we take that one up right now
it was it was uh in the in Express needs
unfunded but now it's Sunday with two
million
oh but that's that's this last that's 53
which is
that's section 89 on front page
that's already in that is the government
what that's governor
okay
is there someone here that can explain
this
I'm on it but I I know I'm surprised to
see my name on it
because I can't
my special order that
tomorrow
well let's don't if we don't know
anything I I don't know anything about
it Mr chair can I read you the
studentclearinghouse.org sure summary of
what the student tracker is
Says student tracker is the only
Nationwide source of college enrollment
and degree data over 3 600 colleges and
universities enrolling over 97 percent
of all students in public and private
U.S institutions regularly provide
enrollment and graduation data to the
Clearinghouse
through student tracker you can query
our participating institutions student
data to perform all types of educational
research and analyzes quickly easily and
affordably
if your institution participates in our
free degree verify and enrollment verify
services and reports additional data
elements you will receive student
tracker at no cost
it's a summary it sounds like
okay
it sounds like student tracker includes
Nationwide post-secondary enrollment and
graduation data for your student group
it says all types of post-secondary
institutions in state out of state
two-year four-year public private trade
school vocationals Etc
student unit level data that you can
combine with your own data to analyze
educational Trends and patterns by any
variable you choose
and unlimited individual student lookups
secure and easy batch file exchanges and
there's
marketing materials here
um
so it sounds like it's a big data
analysis tool
for who yes we should wait for the
department but I believe many years ago
we used to have this and there was a
issue with relation to the data
requested to do the matches
um that we ended up not being able to
fund it anymore so
it's good information because you can
get longitudinal information for
children coming all through the system
into college
um that's my experience with it
um from a long long time ago but the we
really need to hear from the Department
about what they want to do now and how
they're going to be able to uh what kind
of data they're going to need to use in
order to make the match
well hopefully
we'll get somebody
yeah I mean it sounds like it collects
information regarding questions that
we've asked in the past and the answer
has been well we don't collect that data
in terms of college enrollments in
majors and how our students percentage
of students that graduate here compared
to other places vocational training here
compared to other places uh Trends and
what kids are majoring in we've often
had those kinds of questions and the
answer has been I don't know
so this says available to the school
districts
each Public School District anyway
Associated School District level
probably
just
School District
well let's see if we can get somebody
from the Department of Education it
should come up
you have you have knowledge we have
someone in the room with knowledge
um hi I'm Shannon Reed with the
community college system I I'm not
familiar with the amendment what it does
that isn't currently being done but we
do subscribe to it we use the
Clearinghouse to track
um to help us understand the flow of
students into and out of our
institutions
okay
this website is also
helps determine a student's financial
needs so it makes me believe that there
are certain demographic data points for
socioeconomic status that would be
helpful
for you know determining connection
what how do you do your data match
I'm afraid I can't I can't answer that
that's not something that I get involved
in personally
representative Hill do you have more
knowledge on this
we exhausted my knowledge set very
quickly
good morning everyone
um
we're talking about the uh Greg Hill
from uh Northfield remember Mac II uh
catching my breath
um we're here talking about the national
student tracker
so this is a system that uh
seems to be
well known in some circles and others
not the doe does participate already
with student tracker
um 38 cities and towns or school
districts in New Hampshire already
participate with student tracker
this is just simply a bill to to allow
the doe to pay for all districts to have
student tracker and and I would assume
if they want it but it is a um a
recognized tracking system my own school
district is how I learned about it
um
I I had heard about this at a conference
came back to talk to my own school board
and they said
um we've never heard of anything the
superintendent said wait a minute I
think I pay for that so
um it's it was at that time it was four
hundred dollars and they they have
always had the the difficulty or the
problem or the
the desire to be able to learn what
their students do after they graduate
and they said the only way that they
were doing it previously was
um waiting for students to come back
after college and and talk to them and
it was a very imprecise system so when
we discovered that we had this and we're
already paying for it
um the school board started pulling it
apart and finding out that um it's an
extremely valuable tool for them to be
able to find out how successful their
students are after they leave the
confines of their high school with their
graduation so yep um
sure
how do you do thank you and thank you
for taking my question
um how do you match the data do you use
the data the school district has an i-4c
um
you've gone over my ability to know
about it um it I do know that all of the
literature which I have and I can
certainly make copies for you all
um I had come prepared today to to speak
on this
um but not with copies
um but it is
um it it speaks in their literature to
being FERPA compliant it speaks to all
of the student privacy issues that deal
with it and again as I say 38 cities and
towns currently using I just don't know
which ones they were because they
wouldn't even tell me which ones are
using it so that's how how far I I can
go
but it does it does a number of things I
think my district has found different
ways to use it every year
um they're they're looking for Best
Practices they're and and that's the
hope when we do all districts that will
find data that now lets us see where
block scheduling works or something else
you know along those lines
it seems a very reasonable price to me
to get this level of data from an
organization that's been doing it since
I think 1993.
reading the language of the amendment
does not make it clear to me whether
obviously we are paying for it but it's
not clear to me this requires the school
districts to participate or just gives
them the option to participate I would
strongly support the second choice I
would not necessarily support the first
so my understanding when I we had this
discussion on a very limited basis my
understanding is this is the latter that
um that that amount of money is
sufficient for all districts to
participate and and I would add if they
want to
um I don't know why a district wouldn't
but because of I know I know but it is a
it it was important to me that this not
be a 28a issue and it was important to
me to make this as an opportunity that's
available to school districts
yep everybody thank you and thanks for
the explanation
um it sounds like it's very valuable
information from hearing from you and
from Shannon from representative Heath
and it seems like it goes to answer some
of the questions that we've had on
occasion about school so uh presume all
the school districts buy into this they
use this program how does that that
aggregate information get to the
legislature to answer the questions that
we have will there be a way of is there
a will the Department of Education for
instance collect this information put it
into an aggregate so when we ask about
this question of these students you know
going here or going there that we get an
answer because I fully support all the
school districts having this information
it'd be nice in making some of our
decisions if we had a gag or get
information across the state
um thank you for your question I'm not
sure I could um agree with you more
um I think that that because doe already
has a relationship with this
organization that's how we get our state
data
um I would believe that there would be a
on high platform or something like that
that um that there would be a way of of
accessing all of it but but I I can't
get
into the technical weeds of how that
would occur I don't know
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm just reading the first
line of the amendment and I am wondering
if I'm correct in assuming that this
would be a one-time draw of a hundred
and fifty thousand from the Surplus and
the education trust fund uh for June
30th 2023. does that sound correct
general fund oh but thank you General
thank you for your question
I um I do have information uh that I
pulled off the website I'm not sure if
that's helpful or not it does talk to
their privacy commitment on the first so
what what organizations they utilize for
that it talks about and that's the
record-keeping safety for it's called
the I keep safe FERPA badge
um then there's another system that
talks about why student tracker should
be put into every system and what
information can be generated from it
um so all of these things I'm happy to
make available to you
in copies
um or just leave the package and and
Mickey can do what he wants to do with
it
thank you and sorry but I just get
curious
um we've had you know obviously we all
know the difficulty of people turning in
forms around free and reduced lunch and
all that kind of stuff how do how does
this organization how do the school
district provide the economic
information around scholarships that um
representative Higgin Phillips was
reading about when she was reading the
blurb on the organization
um
it's a really good question
all I can say and and again I'll
reiterate that 38 schools are doing this
currently in New Hampshire within our
rules and regulations on privacy
I'm assuming that
um
because on the website they're not
they're very careful to not State
exactly what they do
because they I believe work in
conjunction with our state laws on
privacy so I think each program is
individually
based on the state regulations in that
particular state that they do so I'm not
sure I can answer how it's done but I
would assume because we have 38 cities
uh school districts currently using it
that that it's handled I I just don't
know how yeah thank you I'm just asking
again we're all searching around for
better ways of identifying students uh
for free and reduced lunch and for you
know those kinds of programs so I was
curious thank you yeah I'm I'm not sure
this is your solution but
but it may be I don't know
excuse me uh thank you for taking my
question certainly and the first
sentence says that this is for fiscal
year ending June 30th 2023 which is this
year
so so this appropriation is a draw
against the 23 Surplus and then it
you'll notice on line uh five to six the
appropriation is non-lapsing so it would
be available to spend in the next
biennium thank you
thank you for your question
okay
I don't want to vote on this yet yeah
other comments
I'll just come up here with Greg
um
Rick Ladd Haverhill New Hampshire I just
had a talk with Diana Fenton from the uh
doe she's the attorney for doe also with
the commissioner on the phone not more
and and Greg was there about five
minutes ago this data also explains uh
low poverty type schools uh and provides
aggregate information it's required on
federal applications
uh so this is something they have been
doing it's nothing really new but it's
uh it's required and on these Federal
applications where you're going after
this money to be able to give this
aggregate information about uh cultures
when you're in schools uh poverty levels
within your schools uh we see it also on
graduation rates we see it in regard to
whether you complete College in four or
six years this is information we use in
determining and looking at when we look
at oversight of all this in higher
education and within our our K-12 that
is valuable and needed and we get it
through doe and the national
Clearinghouse has been doing this for
years and they have this all available
on aggregate but this is what we have to
do as paying the access that information
question
honestly at this point I feel that
emotion to approve the amendment would
be appropriate
I'm fine waiting
I think we've got some of the budget
discussions to have
and I will wait no I think we're all in
agreement this is a good idea if we just
find out what the data matches how we
we match the student to the information
I can't tell you that representative I
can't explain that because is it the
facet I have worked with the for example
the president up at PSU prior to uh don
being there and Sarah uh when she was
there and um they use it actively on
that level but we also use it with our
high schools and our counselors use this
information as well and it's nothing new
it's something we have been doing but I
don't know where the Commissioners come
up with those resources I know that even
Virginia Berry was using this
information right here's dating back
right
I remember it well yeah
yeah but we don't know that we don't
know the connect the technical
connection I don't know I don't know it
either
that's beyond our pay grade
most everything is
yeah yeah okay thank you very much
you're welcome all right thank you I'm
going to pass out the other the uh
building Aid
so we can get some discussion going on
that is in your packet so if you go to
page
28 you'll see a revised version of the
representative whole Amendment relative
to his proposal for school building Aid
okay
what what this what this version does is
incorporates the uh the discussion we
had about what is capital
this also has an effective date of
July 1st 2025.
so my thought on this is to
hopefully move this forward not at this
time but in a little while
but there will be plenty of time to work
on it before it goes into effect because
I I think if we're going to do something
like this it still needs to have
weighted for the school districts that
have greater needs than the ones that
don't
so we'll call that the 529 effect
uh
that I I think that this needs to be
right revised with that but I'm still
would like to
to put on notice that an approach like
this is coming down the pipe and we've
got a year and a half to work on it
and I've solicit comments
ulcer number one Mary
um I would like to hear from Amy have
you seen the amendment in me
no it's just clarification of and and
the ADM a
um
admr
looks like the same values are allocated
for admr and adma as previously
presented right
so I don't think our timeline if that's
correct I don't think the timeline
changes for you know
building a to accumulate in these
potential Capital reserves over time at
a local District level I think Amy's
assessment of the timeline has not
changed is is my understanding
so Amy Clark Department of Education
um correct if there's nothing different
from the previous amendment I guess I
don't have anything other AD other than
I would I would say the same thing all
right thank you
yes
yeah other than you know these the the
two changes of the time and then the
line what 25 here
I don't see that this is any different
from what we had before and as I had
said before I have no problem examining
a different you know new models new ways
of looking at things but I think we had
a lot of evidence from Ms Clark and from
representative Ladd that this isn't it
where it's going to be in one scenario
106 years or 160 years before now we're
talking about great grandchildren
benefiting by this and not the children
I think that I heard a lot to say that
this is not going to work and so I
cannot support it even with the minor
chain I think it is a rather minor
change in in the amendment but I am open
to having some sort of a group going
forward and I as I recall too as I say
that
um the education committee is working on
this and they have the knowledge the
experience they have access to the
experts who can provide them with
information they have the time to put
together some sort of a schedule and
spread this out to see how best it would
work but there's not enough change here
at all for me to consider supporting it
I support anything to you know I'm
looking to do something better I'm
always there's always a better way I
don't see that this is it and I cannot
support this I support the education
committee doing their job since this is
their job
okay other comments
just a non-starter for us and it will be
um
impossible
for us to bring this forward to our
caucus
um so
I just I can't see
um any number of
um our side looking at this with any
form of favor and in all honesty I think
even among your ranks um people who have
used and are hoping to get building Aid
will be very disappointed to see a
proposal coming forward like this
because just it's not a realistic
proposal for building Aid and people
have it's been 10 years of a moratorium
it's been 10 years that they haven't
been able to access I don't can't even
begin to tell you how many emails I get
every single day
with regard to building Aid and please
invest in building Aid and this for me
is not an investment in building Aid
thank you very much
the the intention here is to give all
school districts something
because right now we have a list with 17
who have gone through the Hoops uh to to
apply and we're and and of the 17-3 are
being funded
seems it seems like a
a huge amount of effort for three three
school districts yes and the way I was
reading this and I'm kicking myself that
I don't have representative Ladd's
little chart here but it almost looks
like it would take 38 years for one
school to be able to repair a couple
windows and that does nothing for
building Aid
I don't think it's quite that
well take take your own School District
how many students do you have multiply
it out it was 300 K through 8 and 350
High School what does it work out to
guest representative lab
this come up by Amy here
following our discussion on this the
other day I went and refined some of
those figures
um and there there are some huge if
issues here in regard to process
first of all this is an issue which
we've all always considered within house
policy education policy as one of the
top two or three issues which we have to
deal with which requires hearing process
and it really does uh need to have a
careful study done not something that's
done on a two or three page Amendment or
a bill now on what's being passed out I
like to go to the back side of this
now we have a bill which we have
retained for this exact purpose and that
will start immediately but you can see
where it says study methods of ensuring
long-term sustainability funding for
school buildings and identify source of
such funds
we recognize the need here but to look
at the whole Amendment right now
as you imagine represent emmerich
there's no waiting at all of of the
these dollars which go out and certainly
the way we have it right now we have it
weighted 30 percent 25 or 30 35 up to 60
whatever it may be in terms of medium
family income and poverty within the
district this other formula does not
have that at all and you can see on the
last figure there for this school that's
250 kids so the square footage would be
120 square feet per kid up to 144
there's an exception which slides
further I took the lesser of the two and
you can see the cost that building would
be 8.8 million dollars
if in fact we are dealing with a poverty
district and doing it the way it's said
within that bill at three hundred
dollars per pupil it would take 70.8
years for them to Garner the money to do
this do the project 70 years that means
your grandkids are going to see it
before you're going to see it
um not you you know I if I were a kid to
be the grandparents kids of that of that
so there's there's some real questions
here there's also the questions that we
have many districts that don't even have
high schools
and are they going to receive the
funding for that we have districts who
are sending to another state are they
good how how is that going to be handled
there are but the concept is a concept
which needs to be discussed it needs to
be brainstormed it needs to be worked
with the other Concepts we have out
there available to school building a
and so I would encourage you not to push
the policy committee aside which has
that responsibility that is our job it's
not that of an amendment that comes in
this process I'll be frank
if an amendment like this or a bill like
this comes in there will be Republicans
to vote against the bill in total I
being one
so this is such a critical issue in our
state I value how we fund that education
the adequacy which you're also
struggling with
building Aid and Career Technical
education
those are areas which are key to our
future for our Workforce this is
critical for that as well and so please
don't do something rash work with the
policy committee we I could have that
committee up and going and working
seeing we've retain that bill and yes
they won't don't want us to start re
discussing retain bills but I've always
worked with leadership with the clerk
would the speaker and had an exception
of that policy when we have a critical
issue we can start that study
immediately and we should because we
need to have a lot of research got
gathered here as we I've already have
the research assistant doing upstairs
and looking at this very formula that
you're talking about that Kentucky and
Virginia do do
but it's a whole lot different than just
two or three pages of an amendment here
so please slow this ship down a little
bit it's it's not a bad idea but it
needs a lot more work thank you okay
thank you Mr chair Mr chair I would like
to make a motion that we refer this
amendment to
um House Education for future study
reduce that kind of thing
no I think it's that's up to this I
think we can you can take a motion to
you know formally itl if you want this
amendment as far as the work that's
referred to education committee you and
chair lad can work that out I would
encourage folks that are on finance
division two or Finance or those which
involved even for example like a Greg
Hill who is chairing the school building
authority to participate with House Ed
to get us down the path we need to get
down and get some resolution we could
probably have that resolution done by
fall
yes
great uh thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for listening uh we've been
kicking this can down the road for as
long as I've known you
this has been a tough especially during
the moratorium and right now we've got
three districts they're probably going
to get money even with this amendment
and we just keep kicking that can down
the road and we got to fix this I mean
and and it if you can uh I you know I'd
be willing to go along with what you're
saying
with uh you know referring well not
necessarily referring but you're going
to work you've got a study committee
that's going to work on this let me just
say one thing uh represent Petrie that
it's not like it's been out of our
headlights at all we're not trying to
kick this can down the road we have been
trying to work at that we've presented
bill after Bill after Bill to try to
find a way towards the end that you're
trying to get us towards remember the
bill where we were looking for the
survey of all our schools out there so
we could find out what we had in terms
of condition assessment that would have
cost 3.3 million dollars we've had bills
come forward in terms of putting the in
fact there is one that's came forward
this year where to fund School building
Aid we would have 50.50 million dollars
on top of the debt for each year of the
biennium
um I don't think that that's close to
where the governor is where the 75.
um that would help but I'm not here to
justify why you know Concord is not in
it or litchfield's not in it uh this
year's allocation I would like to see
them be involved however I'm here to try
and communicate that we see that there's
a problem
we see that there's a need to clean this
up and we want to move forward and we
are moving forward
um I I think this commitment on the
whole uh House and Senate now to do that
so this is the time it has to be done
let's do it correctly please
well right uh this survey I mean it's
you know some districts want to Taj
Mahal others want full walls for
education and that's you know and we we
should get out of that business I mean
it's not up to the state to dictate what
kind of building you're going to have
right now you can put a theater and I
had a theater up in Alaska where we had
600 people at casino looked like you
were in London watching a play law uh
and however and we had an orchestra pit
and 52 drops on stage but that was paid
well beyond
what we allocated within that Borough
Amy's policies that she has right now
has a minimum this is what we as a state
pay for if you want to have that theater
in your school that's on you Mr District
you do it and and you go beyond that's
you have our blessing but you fund it so
um we do have restrictions right now in
current law the problem we have is
the problem that we're experiencing
right now since we come out of the the
moratorium three buildings we know we
have a huge number a list with huge
dollars how do we address that how do we
address the fact that some schools have
just received building Aid are they
going to be treated the same way as
those that have not yet received
building a we have what how many seven
Amy or so that have received it since
the moratorium maybe more adding this on
are they going to be in the same pot
um that we have some buildings which are
newer than others is that going to be
considered uh all this we need that's
what policy's for well the question you
ask if I mean
part of this this amendment is debt
serves which which helps pay for the
bond
and and it helps pay for the ones that
are out there that that didn't get any
building Aid
and we want to look at that as one of
the options here
are we going to have the debt service
over the period paying back that Bond
over the period of the longevity of that
loan or are we going to put 80 up front
we we see that as something has to
discussed but we want to go well beyond
that we want to go into the domain that
we have represent holes we want to see
if there are there are other ways of
treating this and doing this so that we
can get on with school building support
I can tell you one thing though it's
going to cost dollars and you know that
and it's going to have to be a higher
commitment from the state to allocate
and we we've recognized that already in
policy that's why we have put four
forward unanimously down below each year
to fund 50 million dollars excluding the
debt
and remember that debt that tail is
going to shrink off very rapidly here in
another three years
and you're going to see that there's
going to be more money available and
with that there will be more acceptance
of these projects which are coming
forward to Amy right follow-up uh I
think that you know we that's one of the
problems that I see is that we have to
fund it at a level where it's 12 years
of education or or whatever the building
life is
you know because if we don't do that
then you know then you fall behind every
year I mean you you get further and
further behind it takes you 130 years to
pay I mean I I get that but that means
we have to fund it at a higher level
I mean that plenty is simple
uh thank you yeah this is a seismic
policy shift and
um I think we just keep hearing over and
over again the serious shortcomings of
this
um there's a concept here that may be
considered but this is I mean you can
look at the the page that representative
Ladd put together and what Ms Clark had
talked about before this isn't going to
work this belongs back with education I
would think the appropriate motion here
is to itl this we know they're thinking
about it we know they're working on it
we are not the ones to do the policy and
we are certainly not the experts in the
education and so I think the appropriate
motion is to itl this and let education
be free to do their job this is their
work
all right let's put this one thank you
very much thank you thank you
representative Wilder did you have an
amendment you want to introduce
Escape
before I get to my trust fund
Amendment on my way over
I got stopped by the chairman of
Criminal Justice
who had a conversation
with wait
um the state police
and they point out the fact that
someone could get bailed after they've
been arrested
say in Manchester
get out on the street and go back up
some way to Conway or someplace and get
arrested again
get bailed again and the people in
Conway don't know he's already on bail
so they went to their their uh vendors
that do their
their system and say they could fix this
for a million dollars
so that
all the state police would be aware of
or who the police departments would be
aware of who had been bailed that they
just arrested so they've already should
be a revocation of bail and sent back to
the original place so however they want
to deal with it but the point is
people could run every time they're
they're released on bail and go and do
another crime
and keep getting bailed it seems like
they're bailing too easy so to bring
that forward when you get to your safety
this department of safety discussion
State Police but anyway back to
the adequacy education trust fund in
1999 we sat down we discussed what
adequacy was we came up with a figure we
funded it on the on the student count
there was
and we found ways to fund it through the
various funding sources
and that's what we did and it increased
every every year by CPI
so
what's happening now is
the sources we fund it with have
increased and the adequacy has gone down
as the we've had a very dramatic
decrease in student population since we
passed this
so
I want to return to the original purpose
of Education trust fund which was just
to fund adequacy and we deliberately
made it a little less because some years
before we had that bill
we had money coming from Lottery
we put in the budget 103 million 102
million because that's what the
estimated previously then they ended up
with 105 million so there were three
million more going to education than we
had anticipated we'd already put all the
other money in there so they got three
million more
then we had anticipated but they spent
it
we could have used that 3 million in a
couple of other places that were a
little short
but instead they had a surplus and they
spent it
so we always made sure that adequacy was
a little less
from the sources of revenue then
what we thought we needed and we'd fill
it up with General funds General funds
were also used for for special ed they
were used for tuition and transportation
they were used for building Aid they
were used for all these other things the
only thing education trust fund was for
was for adequacy
so I I'm bringing in an amendment that
returns to its roots by reducing the
amount of
money that is taken out of the education
out of the Business Center business
Enterprise and business profits taxes so
that only enough is is going in there to
cover some of the things that are
inadequacy which usually in now includes
other things like um
you know the
charter school funding
um
and education Freedom accounts
kindergarten Aid public and things like
that so
this would reduce
the amount of money there is still the
same amount of money available but now
we're not trying to use up the education
trust fund by putting it here and
putting it there when it I took some of
those things ought to compete with
everything else that competes with
general fund over here we might be short
several places
in general fund while over here we're
looking for some place to spend that we
can call education
and it's it's not a good way to manage
the budget the only money that should go
in there because of the way we we
originated the education trust fund was
for adequacy all the other things will
compete on a regular basis with
everything else that's in the general
fund so that's my intent that's the way
it was historically for you know since
2000 uh since 2000 so that's what I'd
like to go back to because now it's it's
coming up with a surplus which previous
budget we took 100 million out of it it
shows you how much more it's bringing in
than it really needed
so that 100 million there were several
other places it could have been used so
that's that's the reason for the
amendment
um and that's what it does
happy to answer any questions I know
there's going to be one here
thank you Mr chair
thank you
for taking my question so you put forth
this proposal
um
today is really the last day that we
have to work
um
is this proposal for the budget we're
working on now
it it makes very little change to the to
the budget as as you've proceeded so far
it just puts the education trust fund
back to its original purpose and its
original numbers
but if I may
um we have a number of other items we
have building Aid we have special ed Aid
there are a number of things that are
included in the trust right now
um we even have the CTE Center that's in
the trust right now
and where do you propose
you're taking
everything out of the trust right now
and moving it into general fund right
for those items that we have approved
will they be moved over a degree general
fund it's too late in the process and
I've lectured people on this many times
it's too late in the process for big
changes this isn't a big change
it's just saying
this is now funded from this rather than
that but it's still funded to the same
amount so with all due respect I'm
trying to figure this out so you're
telling me that this isn't change
and all this all the things that we're
working on now are
can we just put this into effect for the
next biennium and not this one
Mr Mr chair please
as long as it goes into effect we need
to restore the education trust fund to
what it was so we don't sit here saying
oh we got extra money to spend an
education over here but gee was short
over there in general funds I don't want
to ever have that happen so would you be
opposed if I'm in a motion that the
impact of this amendment would not be
effective until the next biennium
you're free to make any motion you want
Mr chair I would like to move that this
amendment
um be given an effective date for um the
biennium beginning in 26 Mickey am I
correct
if the intent is to have this affected
the next biennium yes it'd be one July 1
2025.
I oppose that because I think this needs
to be made sooner than later and it
doesn't affect the intent is not to
affect any of the decisions you have
made so far
do we have a second
foreign
no no I just have a couple questions if
I could
um you know the governor's proposal
loses this is 65 to 35. we don't have it
do we have a second
okay motion dies okay
um the Tasmania the 65 to 35 percent uh
the governor's change
um to the allocation and you've moved it
from 77.5 to 22.5 which is a to me
that's a big that's a significant change
and I'm just sort of wondering uh what
you're basing that on and why you're
opposed to the governor's proposal here
and
um I would also you know I could think
it's pretty easy to argue that special
education is education and education
belongs in the education trust fund and
to see that it's going from you know 96
in at 96 million education down to three
and a half that's also a significant
change so
um I certainly understand that there can
be too large of a surplus and it's
probably probably not appropriate to
hold some of that in the education trust
fund but what I see you doing here is
essentially draining the education trust
fund which is not something I can
support but I guess if you can address
how you came up with your numbers as
opposed to the governor's numbers which
I think are more appropriate and why
can't special education be part of
Education
it wasn't for 20 years it was in general
funds
it was always that way for 20 years the
only reason it's been taken up is
because the education trust fund had a
surplus obviously last budget had a
hundred million that was taken out so
that money could have been used
somewhere else rather than it was good
that it went as a tax cut however I
still haven't seen the tax cut in my tax
bills so it seemed like
so you're saying that special education
shouldn't be funded by education I mean
the fact that it was in there for 20
years isn't part of adequacy
but the the fact that it wasn't in the
education trust fund doesn't necessarily
mean that it shouldn't belong there that
maybe there's a good reason there's
explanation for having it in the trust
fund Beyond adequacy
adequacy was a very set amount it's now
gone for 20 plus years until we've
suddenly decided we're going to spend it
here and we're going to spend it there I
don't like the idea of that saying well
we can put this in education trust fund
it should not have a surplus because it
robs some other places that are just as
important
adequacy was to defend us from a lawsuit
and it did that for 20 years
so
I would like to make sure that it's back
to its original roots and its two
decades of of serving its purpose and
it's gotten away from that because of
this huge reduction in student
population that has occurred since we
passed it in 99.
thank you Mr chair again for letting me
take questions
um so
part of the reasons why the education
trust has seen the revenue increase that
it's seen is because of the
really
aggressive
um economy that we saw especially during
the pandemic now you mentioned the um
lawsuit
um
Mr chair we we have another lawsuit
coming in all probability if there's
actually two I believe in place and how
will it look
to the courts
for us to be taking money from the trust
instead of putting money into the trust
or even just leaving it is and really
applying those funds I would encourage
you to really think about this proposal
as of right now in terms of how the
courts will perceive your actions
the lawsuit is not in the same area of
adequacy that going after the
tax on utilities that's what the
lawsuit's about so I don't see it as
being in the same vein
question
uh Mr Weiler chairwyler
um while I was on the campaign Trail
this past season
um I spoke to almost every constituent
in my district and their number one
concern was with protecting public
schools and the funding mechanisms for
that
I'm wondering
um this this proposal seems to be a
Monumental shift in the way
our state chooses to fund public
education in the state and I'm wondering
you know when you were you know maybe
you could share your perspective on you
know why this is such a priority in your
District
nobody even knows where the money is
coming from they just know they're
getting
and and from our budget we've put out
over a billion dollars a year to the
towns that's all they're looking at they
don't know how much is going to Highway
block grant and they don't know how much
is is going to
paying for water repairs all they know
is how much are we getting from the
state that's the only thing that people
mention they all want to make sure
schools are funded and we all do we've
never decided not to fund schools we've
never really cut back on the education
amount we sent to schools as they say
it's a major part of our budget
so as long as the money is coming in
nobody really cares what column it's
coming and that's those of us that deal
with
the financial part of it care what
column it's in but the the people that
are getting the money they don't care
they'll still get the same amount we've
always funded Special Ed we've always
funded building Aid we've always funded
these things so and transportation and
tuition those have always been funded
from general fund
nobody cared where the money was coming
from as long as they were getting the
money
and so we made sure that they had they
get the money
and I remember special ed we would go up
sometimes 12 a year and it wasn't enough
you could never tell what's special end
what the cost would be so if you put
something like that in education trust
fund you never know what it'll be it is
so unpredictable
it could go down one year that would be
an amazing thing but you know if you try
to fit it in a set funding source you'd
be very unsuccessful it has to compete
with everything else that comes up that
year you may have to make a cut
somewhere else so you could fully fund
it but the funding we do we take care of
here in division two I've been in
division two since 1992.
and we've always managed to fund
everything that education needed so I
don't see that this is going to imperil
any of the funding that education gets I
just want to have its return to its
roots that was respected for 20 years
and now has gotten off the tracks I want
to bring it back to what it was intended
for and what it worked for for 20 years
okay yeah thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr chairman for taking my question
does this anyway affect the governor's
proposal in any way
it goes along with it
it tweaks it because because we're
increasing adequacy or through the
governor's proposal we actually headed
in his budget to reduce the amount
coming out of business Enterprise tax
and business profits tax it was in his
proposal I was thinking along those same
lines and I thought yes this is moving
in the right direction I made a little
tweak that's what it amounts to he may
like it
thank you
um thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr chair
um can you guarantee me
that the things that we've approved that
we're working on now will be
approved
will continue to be approved
I have voted for most of the things in
division two that got passed and I have
gone along with almost all the things
and unless we come at the last minute
and say oh my word we're
10 million over 20 million of them was
have to go back and make cuts that may
happen but I'm ready to support
everything division two has done to date
unless something else comes up
thank you Mr chair
um just one more plea just because we're
in the middle of things and today is the
last day and I can't even imagine how
much work Mickey has and for him to have
to do the shifts for all of this into
the general fund I think it's adding a
lot of work for him it's adding
confusion for us on the last hour I
would really like you to consider the
start date for this at another time
thank you Mr chair I have given uh
Mickey enough heads up on this that I
think he's already done the work
so I don't think it's going to be a real
great burden on him I think he's way
ahead of the rest of us thank you
I would appreciate a quick summary just
because there is a lot of data of what
are the governor suggested changes and
what are what you know what's different
in this amendment just honestly to get
it into the record too as a clerk
may need some help Mickey it's it's the
areas on
the
if you go to page five of this packet
essentially the highlighted the shaded
rose indicate the changes affected by
this amendment which page page five
so you'll see online 15 and 16 is the
increase in the portion of the business
taxes that would go to the general fund
versus the education trust fund so when
the governor's recommended budget those
amounts were based on their revenue
projections approximately 73 million
dollars per year that would shift over
and this goes up to 223 224 so about 150
million per year more than the governors
of Revenue shifting between the two
funds
and then special education Aid tuition
and transportation School building Aid
the court ordered placements as well as
the new episode of treatment payments
that this committee adopted earlier be
building a lease which is relative to
Charter Schools and the CT renovation uh
the 12 and a half million we're all in
the governor's recommended budget as
education trust fund if you flip to page
six of this packet you'll see those
figures presented there in the at the
current levels that this division has
them at would be shifted to the general
fund
so there is no decrease to any of the
aid programs
in this amendment here just shifting
between education trust fund to general
fund I appreciate the clarifications
and the funds go with the and the funds
go with so the revenue the revenue
changes where the funds would go with it
so the revenue would go to the general
fund and these Appropriations would be
shifted to the general fund so the total
ins and out of the general fund would
increase ins and out of the education
trust fund would decrease Net Zero
gives us the needed flexibility as an
overall
budget
question yeah thank you and thanks for
the overview there I just I can agree
that there are some things here that
could appropriately be moved out of the
education trust fund
um I think the 12 percent change from
the 65 to the 77 percentages is more
than a tweak I think that's a pretty
significant change so I have an
objection to that and I do think that
there's um you know you're right that
people aren't looking at the budget in
terms of what comes from where but I
think it'll be there'll be push but
there'll be quite a shock for special ed
people when they see the special ed is
not in the education trust fund and
there's a sense of guaranteeing it'll
get funded when it's in the education
trust fund and I think that Assurance
goes away if it's taken out of the trust
fund if you ask them how many years
General uh how many years special ed was
not funded in the education trust fund
they would not have a clue
that's probably I'm sure you're
absolutely right but there is a
statement of importance that it is in
the education trust fund
only in this budget
many previous budgets did not have it in
education trust fund
20 years of them
but still it got funded
question thank you Mr Mr chairman so I I
don't see where
um this is just a simple percentage or
calculated uh change it it looks like
every single item that's every item that
is has to be recalculated for business
profits business Enterprise
Motor Vehicles
tobacco taxes real estate taxes
um sweepstakes and Lottery
tobacco
the tobacco settlement tax
amount every single item has to be
recalculated
so the only Revenue change here
representative Buco is the business
profits and business Enterprise tax so
you'll see on lines 15 and 16 the
revenue adjustments associated with
those so this the share of BPT would
actually still be an increase of 23.2
million dollars and 23.5 million dollars
but the big decrease is relative to the
business Enterprise tax I see that on
line 16. so the net of those is about
224 million dollars per year
I don't think that I'm following the
lines that you're on so on page five of
the amendment packet
the is that representative Weiler 1105
Amendment packet
you see that on lines 15 and 16.
lines again please so lines 15 and 16.
okay thank you
thank you Mr chair
um one of the things that I just wanted
to mention that in fact
um there was a time that in fact we
actually when we were in the majority we
actually moved building a special ed Aid
um and a few of these things into the
um trust because the trust was very
healthy that year and the general fund
they were um in the other two divisions
they were really struggling and this was
a way to help the budget and that's why
we've been moving forward all these
things seem to support the education
process so it seemed a very positive
move and I thought it was a very
effective one
um and and again it released the general
fund from this that's kind of the
history behind it so I think it's one
two three bienniums Mickey that I think
we changed it
I think it was the 1819 yes I believe
that's correct
so thank you
2021 sorry I'm off of biennium
hey what's a buy animal with friends
any other comments
yeah if I can just you know as I think
that there are things to you to discuss
here that there is um an appropriate
action to be taken I'm not I'm pretty
sure this is not one that I could
support and I have to say it's kind of a
tough gig to bring it in at literally
the 11th Hour uh when we've been having
this since beginning you know
mid-February or so that um this becomes
uh more of a challenge and it would have
been appreciated I mean it this is the
11th hour and I don't think this is a
very good time to bring in an amendment
that makes such a significant change I
had to wait until I saw how much was
spending in each of the areas before I
could bring it forward and figure out
exactly what the tweak would be on what
the governor had suggested that's why I
waited till this last hour wanted to see
what those Figures were
like uh one of the things we we made a
commitment as a legislature to fund two
ctes
usually that goes in the capital budget
we can't do they can't do it they don't
have enough money so that's one of the
reasons why you've probably put it in
this amendment and made sure it was
getting paid but but as long as it's
paid and fulfill our commitment we've
done what we've set out to do
and it would likely have come out of
General funds anyway
questions um
so my first question is we've been
looking at variations of a school
funding formula
does this change that
I don't remember us looking at
variations and yes we have like
529 I think it was yes we we've done
that consistently that doesn't change
that that still ends up as adequacy so
but can we continue our work on the
formulas that we're working on this
doesn't change that and my second
question
sorry on line 17
automatic support from the general fund
goes away and then it requires fiscal
for them to go to the fiscal committee
so what what will that result in
what will be the impact of that
what's that on line 17 yes of your
Amendment
but I think I might be able to answer
this So currently the department of
education does not have a mechanism to
draw additional general or education
trust funds during a biennium without
legislation if you recall when doe came
in they had suggested having an ability
to go to fiscal to draw an education
trust fund to cover administrative costs
that are not in their budget so this
amendment does include that provision
that this committee had discussed before
thank you
yes
oh question yeah I'm um this is more of
a comment uh Mr chair
um you know
I have um great concern about this
amendment but
um I also have deeper concern for the
process involved in this proposal I
think you know we are not subjecting
this to a public hearing at any point
and given the 11th hour I think we are
missing stakeholder input and
um you know I know I know chairman
Weiler Prides himself on the process and
the Integrity of this committee
um and I think that it's missing a
significant piece of the puzzle here
I I don't feel comfortable moving
forward with us without you know hearing
from the public at large about what
their opinions are clearly there is 20
years of legislative history since these
changes have gone into effect and to
unwind that as the chairman has even
stayed in his own testimony no one knows
where the money comes for it I don't I
don't remember him saying that anyone
has specifically asked for this and that
you know I think moving forward it would
be a large
um
I think it would be a significant
mistake to move so quickly at 11 30 on
the day that our deadlines are due
without hearing from the greater public
at large about this proposal so I I'm
just putting on the record that I can't
support this
yeah thank you Mr chairman uh I think if
uh if you remember what the chairman
Weil said was that it was in the public
it was in the governor's eye he alluded
to doing this
and so it has been out there and people
have been able to comment and they have
you know they have the ability to you
know and we've been
constantly bombarded by constituents as
to what goes on and I think this is the
best
you know
way to proceed on this because
we can't take other other things out of
the trust fund but if there's money
there we can't afford things in the
general fund and all this money sitting
there that can't be used I mean that's
we we got to see that I mean it's
it's almost a no-brainer
yes question
I'm just curious if any committee memory
members are steering that very long
public input session on HP one hp2
getting even one comment on the proposed
changes in the funding of the education
trust fund from the public because I
really don't but I could have missed
something so
Mr chairman I move this amendment uh
2023 1105 h
as
okay
I'll second that
by show of hands we have a motion to
ought to pass
all those in favor
five
a post
for
okay so the motion passes
and I'm just going to clarify the motion
here
the house bill 2 Amendment as well as
the swap of funding that's detailed on
the last two pages of this packet so
there will be a dollar for dollar
appropriation shift for those programs
from the education trust fund to the
general fund in house bill one and I
also want to point the committee to one
previous action that we will just have
to revisit so if you go to page 21 of
your big Amendment packet that I passed
out earlier today our episode of
treatment Amendment the five House Bill
521 language that we added to host Bill
2 there's an appropriation associated
with that we had left that as education
trust funds at that time but as part of
this amendment
uh that we just adopted I will redraft
the episode of treatment so if you look
up page 21 that Roman 5 talks about
education trust fund in the statute for
this so I'll update that to be general
fund so I look at that as a technical
required to facilitate the amendment you
just adopted okay
I think as long as everyone just
understands that the emotion you just
took on this amendment will have a
couple other technical fixes that I'll
make okay
we'll switch that to General funds and
statute to align with the action on
Amendment 1105 each
okay now we're back to the
and the motion is by representative
Heath who is this oh sorry I'm sorry
I was looking at the wrong part of the
book here thank you for correcting me
got it
okay
back to our our
s i i do I I needed some clarification
on adequate suggestions because we
talked about it briefly
and we had been discussing in committee
adding 20 million dollars per year to
the right side of of the equation
uh I I just need to get some
thoughts or Direction
we basically have two different
documents one is the original document
that is
was dated uh 320
.
and then we have
then we have another one
this was the original
eight and a half 11 landscape
I guess the the question the question
comes up is do we have the 20 million
dollars each year available to put on
the right hand side of the for of the
formula
if
not moved with the formula
the governor the governor's
what what we did what we discussed was
the in the governor's uh formula
the right hand side starts to accelerate
in year two
our thought was to accelerate it in Year
One
and reduce the increase from 50 percent
to 35 percent in future years
but if we don't have the 20 million
dollars each
year to put in
then we revert back to the governor's
formula
education education trust fund but
that's what that's what part of this
whole discussion
not with not not with the action you
just took so now we have a new education
trust fund situation which is page five
of the amendment package so through
decisions to this point there's
3.449 million dollars in the education
trust fund so any further actions of
increasing any of the remaining programs
in the education trust fund would put
the fund into deficit and be a general
fund transfer
thank you
around these other places
the The Proposal that was talking about
is is adding an additional 20 million
per year above and beyond the governor's
funding level
this is this is not a funding Swap this
is new money that's being discussed now
so will and the new money was supposed
to be in the education trust fund yeah
but so far we've used up the education
trust fund
even under the old standards there
wasn't 20 million extra in there and
these figures you had so the other one
prior to that there there was and that
that was the page four of this handout
if you go back
20 minutes ago where we were to we had
it there was 96 million so that net 92
million or so
is now in the general fund based on the
adoption of amendment 1105h
it's in the general fund without
assignment correct but it's within this
committee correct so that's that would
be the source
so if if this committee were to proceed
with increasing adequacy
they were just again historically that's
what we've always done we're always
intentionally underfunded adequacy so if
it went over we wouldn't have that money
locked up we always underfunded adequacy
which this is this goes along with what
we've done for 20 years so yes the
money's there
yeah if this if this showed 96 million
that was unassigned on this page it's
still unassigned do we need emotion
well we're going to proceed with the
most comparable the the 40 million is
going to have to come out of general
fund yes but it's within this division
right
so the question but there's the other
question is do
that means we're going to be spending
more than the governor
but overall will you be spending more
than the governor
40 million more
then why was the 96 million shown as a
balance
the governor's budget had 148 million
dollars at the end of 25 is a balance so
with Revenue estimates change with a
couple of the policy differences this
has been a moving number based on the
decisions that the full committee and
division two has made and that's just
where we were going into today and then
you can see the change of of the
amendment so it's really up to
the division how you want to proceed
here so the governor showed a surplus
yes and he didn't assign it correct okay
so now we still have a 90 because of
this we still have the 96 million is it
yep the 96 now is down to 3.5 without a
memo you just adopted
right but it's in the general funds now
so it's part of the bigger
bigger pot of money for all across all
three divisions
this is the 96 and they want to spend 40
of it here
which will still keep us from from going
over the governor's budget
are you talking about for adequacy
specifically or The Total Money the
total that would be coming I don't know
what's going on in the other divisions
to say no but in this within this
division within this Division if you
combine General and education yes you
you
uh
Appropriations no if you added 20
million per year but as far as available
funds from within the education trust
fund that you switched in uh I think
that those weren't funds that were
counted on at some point in this process
I don't know if that 90 million or so
shifting between education in general is
part of your bigger picture for the
other divisions so I can't answer that
no it was not taken into account all the
divisions are expected to reduce their
budgets to the 85 million deficit that
we saw after we passed the ways and
means Revenue estimate and I think from
what I spoke to your boss I think uh
Elba Mike Kane I think was coming very
close to that so yeah
it's really a priority of the division
what you want to end with for balances
so
how much you want to spend versus how
much you want to have at the end of the
biennium or the end of fiscal 23 and
fiscal 25 to the rainy day fund those
are decisions that would be impacted
by if you just if you do an additional
20 or not for adequacy understood so you
want to spend 40 million a year or 40
million total 40 total total 20 20 per
year
okay so you'd still be left with with 56
correct not a problem
okay
okay thank you
as I said historically we've always
added money to adequacy from the general
fund this is nothing new
it's finally so everybody feels
comfortable the 96 million we have 40
million that we're going to apply toward
the adequacy formula and the remainder
of the 96 million apart from the 40
million that we're spending will be
retained in division two over which we
will have discretion to spend is that
correct that's correct I just asked for
a million dollars for the state police
now you can use it I think we couldn't
before okay
you could use it for the 40 million and
you'll have a million that you can use
for the State Police so everybody knows
who's been bailed when they arrest them
I think that's a good thing
so that's not an hb2
or is that just ice cream one no not yet
I just brought it I just brought it in
as an amendment because I was requested
from the chair of Criminal Justice
so that's another assignment for Mickey
to work on and for you to prove later
you might want to discuss it with the
state police okay
yes I just want to double check again
because chairman Weiler is the only
person in the room that has visibility
across all three divisions if those
funds are available in terms of the
bottom line overall because I want to
make sure we are prudent and we don't
end up agreeing on something and then we
meet as a full committee and we discover
that we're well wildly over I I would
just like to understand where we are in
terms of that because you know it
changes the way I would support or not I
want to do it but not if it's
irresponsible I think division one has
made some of the biggest Cuts division
three is is seeking to do a 15 increase
in Medicaid and they're moving a lot of
pieces around the budget call for 3.1
percent but all the people that
testified before them virtually every
Department said oh we need much more we
need much more some we heard some of
that at the public hearing about and and
hearing about
nursing homes going broke they can't
hire people for the money that's
available and all they're getting is
Medicaid and Medicaid is insufficient
for everything so they're trying for a
big Medicaid addition they're already
echoing what the Senate did the Senate
added 40 million to the Medicaid
distributions which of course will be
doubled with with the federal input
so they're they're kind of moving their
pieces around to meet that goal I don't
know if we're going to get as much
saving there as we will in in division
one but division one has has got some
big pieces that they are looking at that
will likely make it balance well and I
think we just division two just
basically moved 50 million dollars over
to General funds
that's going to be a big help yeah
okay just to clarify does that it does
mean that we have the financial
wherewithal to increase the education
funding to by you know the 20 million
per year as requested in your opinion
yes I would vote for that thank you
that's where we are
getting ready to vote for that you want
to show move it or I'll stay here and
then I got to go to division three well
you don't have all the numbers I'm
because where we are is um is on this
one a portrait looking
document
uh
all right
we started here with multiple proposals
on the one that's still elusive
that graduated into this version that
has proposals 10 11 and 12 on it that
include the 40 million dollars
uh and and we also decided to round off
some of the pennies to make the straight
dollars
we haven't taken a vote yet on whether
we're in favor of proposal 10 11 or 12.
so that's where we are as far as
adequacy
uh this also incorporates the two
percent increase each year instead of
for the biennium and also with the two
percent goes to the
EV
pfr whatever
yeah the equalized valuation per frame
reduced lunch pupil okay so there's two
things going on here the proposals had
applied the two percent increase to both
the thresholds and the grant
so if you remember the governor
Governor's budget included each biennium
for the next five or six bandages
increasing the equalized value or excuse
me the extraordinary needs Grant from
650 times fifty percent each biennium so
that would extrapolate up to about 5 000
by the Max Grant on the out years
if you take one of these proposals you
can see that you're starting your
extraordinary needs Branch much higher
than 650. so the committee will have to
decide on the out years multiplier if
you even want one uh because if you keep
the governor's recommended of 50
starting at 37.50 for instance in
proposal 10. that'll extrapolate very
quickly and get very expensive and I'm
not sure that's the intent so you well
you know if we did we could back into a
percent growth rate to apply to the
maximum Grant to essentially get to the
same end point as the governor around
five thousand
um over 10 years just whatever that rate
each biennium would be I was I'd have to
back into it depending on what you
settle on okay yeah
is that a number we would need to obtain
from Mickey before we vote or is it
enough to give him the general guidance
that we are looking to put in 20
whatever the 20 million a year in
whichever of the proposals I'm gonna
only support 10 but
um and then he is expected to then
adjust the hb2 language the percentage
of growth so that at the end of the
governor's plan we reach the exam amount
of dollars so we just start from a
higher base and grow more slowly to get
to the same endpoint I just want to make
sure that this is the intent of the
committee and that it's allowable to
make those motions because
that's the intent okay
it's somewhere in the five percent range
is what it would be so instead of 50 to
5 by that fifth biennia you would get to
the fifth by item you'd get to about
where the governor was going to Max it
out so you're starting you're you're
moving a lot of that Aid Front in the in
the 10-year plan essentially yeah with a
slower growth but to get to the same
point because you're starting at a
higher point if you went with like
proposal 10 for instance okay
everybody understand that all right so
what's what's anybody's pleasure oh I'll
make that motion for proposal 10.
and have it end up
what she was talking about to end up at
the same as the governor's proposal
so we just to clarify for everyone
proposal 10 is base Aid 4700 per pupil
frame reduced lunch 2500 per pupil
sped rate 2100 per pupil and English
language learner 800 per pupil third
grade reading would remain repealed as
proposed by the governor the thresholds
in fiscal 24 would be one million to 6
million for equalized valuation per free
and reduced lunch pupil and the maximum
grant for the extraordinary need Grant
would be 37.50
and we will do the biennial increase to
the grant amount of five or I'll just
double check the math I think it's going
to be probably five for a round number
and the question is do you want to index
the thresholds so the one million and 6
million are in statute do you want to
add the two percent or eight the five
percent to those thresholds so those
would increase in time
that's up to the committee
that was something we had talked about
before because otherwise those one
million is 6 million would remain the
same even in the out years and it
doesn't factor in inflation
okay we have a second
okay
we'll incorporate what you just said
well I what's what's the decision on
that do you want to do two percent to
keep a uniform with the grant amounts
are you doing do you want to do five
percent to keep it uniformed with the
increase of the maximum Grant I think
both are probably going to results not
much difference over the the duration
yeah
I would suggest that too just because we
really want to because Houston
throughout the entire proposal and uh
you know there is no point in creating
different percentage rates a different
percent of the parts of the formula it's
complex enough as it is so two percent
would apply as the governor proposed to
all the the cost of an adequate
education components every year
two percent will also apply every year
to the one to six million dollar ratio
thresholds and then five percent will
start next biennium each biennial
adjustment to the Max Grant the governor
proposed 50. you're going to do the same
model but five percent yes
that was his motion yes I think that's
the way I understood it too that's
perfect I documented it here in 10 words
and we have also been made yes
yes questions yeah just to make a
comment that I think you know proposal
10 is certainly an improvement over what
we're doing now there's a lot good about
it but I'm not going to support it
because I think proposal 11 is a better
proposal and I want to be able to keep
that conversation open and be able to
speak to it at some point should that
become appropriate okay
and I would concur with that I just want
to remind us all that we really
dedicated our efforts to try to find
more Equity to those school districts
that have that are struggling and I
believe that that a proposal number 11
does a better job than number 10. thank
you
I don't disagree
uh
but I think to keep representative puko
for being tarred and feathered
he the top line was the 4700 so I'm
looking out for his best interest yeah
and thank you he
proposal Janet gets uh money
okay so let's ready for the vote
on this elaborate adequacy funding
although all those in favor of
the motion on proposal ten one two three
four five five those opposed
copy and paste
four okay so the adequacy for proposal
10 moves forward
thank you
now we have now that we know that we
have it what is anybody's interest in uh
can I I'm sorry Mr chair while we're
while we're flying through with adequacy
here can we just flip to page 31 of our
Amendment packet because we can clean up
representative Mooney's Charter School
bill at this time right our Charter
School Amendment
so page 31
so if you recall as this bill came to us
the per pupil Grant was the additional
Grant rather for Charters was increased
to 46.27 and I believe the intent of
this bill was to get the total amount
with base plus the additional Grant to
be nine thousand right so I've already
updated this amendment to include the
one the two percent increase to have it
uniformed with adequacy so on line eight
if you adjust the 46 27 to 4300 even I
think that gets us to the Target of nine
thousand per pupils since you're
supporting the 4 700 for base adequacy
there will be a little bit of an uh
I'll do the math but this may not cost
you much at all because uh you know it
was already in there yeah we the the
charter well actually let me back up
it's not going to cost you as much as
the fiscal note said because it was 4.9
million dollars a year is what we were
carrying for this bill but by reducing
this to 4 300 it'll be somewhere less
than that so I'll do that math along
with the adequacy math and
so I kind of emotional move
bite
for a second okay all those in favor
okay hey we're in Anniston hey back to
the good old days
okay what bill was that
that amendment is uh it's got to be
Rewritten yeah it's Amendment eight
correct and we'll we'll update that
amount thank you the 4300
okay so now we go to Amendment 111h with
the 150 000 for
the the
student tracker program
okay that emotional motion made second
all those in favor
okay that was easy we'll move right
along
foreign
I think that's it
I was going to say I think we could
time is it can I ask a quick question
sure all right we just spent forty
thousand dollars but we still have 40
million yeah right I'm sorry I keep
doing that just 40 million sounds like
such a huge number to me just I have
like one million we wouldn't point you
got it yeah we just spent 40 million
dollars out of the 96 million dollars so
we even though it's been moved to the
general fund
uh chairwyler said that we still have
access to those dollars so we can go
back to the the discussions we were
having after lunch
um knowing that we have that money
available to us am I correct
that is what representative Weiler said
uh as far as that's what I heard what
big picture is I can't I can't answer
that okay so during lunch we'll come up
with a wild way to spend about 50
million
okay Beyond everything
which ones that okay well we'll we'll
recess until one o'clock oh building
hey we're the Penny Pinchers come on
which of them
different stack of papers just yeah
just a second
of the problems
I do I do remember I don't remember if
it was a formal vote but I believe there
was consensus among the committee that
at the newer levels you know the reduced
adjusted levels sharpened levels
it uh I mean I I think there was
consensus that it is you know whether we
need a foreign
uh you're moving you have a second yeah
three instead of five it was five
million per year the original
recommendation I believe
uh no I'm sorry eight eight yes eight
not not five the original request was
eight right the the reduction that they
came forward with was five million
reduction to get to 3 million a year
that's the most all those in favor
unanimous okay
recess again that will recess
let's run before it changes again
wow that was a big trick
thank you
being one o'clock and we'll
revisit our work session which we're
about done with
um
one item that uh
blvas brought up as the highway fund
because last term I think the Senate
appropriated 20 million additional for
the highway fund is that what they said
uh
was that that didn't the Senate put 20
million in the highway funnel yeah the
last budget did include a I can't
remember the exact number that sounds
about right uh we'll put the center for
the senator yeah it happened later in
the process so uh so you're on page
eight now of the packet this is the
highway fund snapshot that we're working
from and this incorporates the changes
that we have approved to this point that
impact the highway fund as well as those
fiscal items I was telling you about
yesterday I think winter maintenance and
there's a safety one so so that that
ending balance now and we usually will
balance on a gap basis in the highway
fund is 5.7 million so the committee
could consider who we've discussed this
before doing a transfer from the general
fund to the highway fund uh to just add
a little bit of dollars there so there's
a little bit of a cushion yeah and uh
the only Highway fund request
that the Department of Transportation
had was on where they had two actually
on page three
they had requested additional funds for
equipment and those telematics which uh
I'm sorry on lines 39 and 40.
and those were not included in the
governor's recommended budget uh
either so
so with with the actions taken earlier
today I I can't say there's X dollars to
spend because again I don't know what
the other committees are doing if this
committee did want to entertain a 10
million dollar for instance transfer
from the general fund to the highway
fund to add some cushion here
we could do that we're going to end up
we're going to end up tallying up all
all the divisions work today and
see where we are
so they could use that 10 million for
this equipment purchase if they wanted
and you could appropriate that too so if
you if you and you don't have to do the
full amount either right so the amount
that they brought forward was
5 million for the biennium 4.7 so you
could do something for instance one
million or two million per year or
whatever whatever number you pick up to
that request and then pick X dollars to
transfer into the highway fund and that
would essentially cover it okay
okay
total of 10 total ten
so it would be five and five what we
would probably do is just do a 10
million dollar transfer of 23 Surplus
into the highway fund okay so that would
flow through and then right and then you
could if you wanted to entertain
increasing their equipment line by an
amount you see their request but you can
pick what you want
not unless you appropriate those
so the 10 goes into the highway fund but
then you need to authorize them to spend
it they can't just spend Highway funds
without your authorization
moved 10 million
into the highway into the highway second
out of 23 circles
you have a second
okay okay now and you had a comment
I did have a question
um if I recall correctly uh earlier we
were already overdrawn on the Surplus
what happens if we allocate funds for
the Surplus and then uh you know
will when will we have the opportunity
to correct that because how does it work
so
how it's going to work this year is
we're going to once the dust settles on
all the work the three committees are
doing we're going to recommend the
chairs
recess
and we're going to go back and tally
everything up and you need to leave
Friday open basically as a potential day
that we need to revisit depending on
how everything shakes out and what you
want to do at that point as a committee
that's that's where we're at we we can't
really offer real time how much money is
available for division two because we
don't know what the other two divisions
are doing likewise for them
this goes at one o'clock I believe on
Friday so
the idea would probably be at one plan
on 10 o'clock Friday as a just in case
and sometime tonight or tomorrow we'll
communicate to the chairs and you can
decide if you feel you need to come back
in division
that's how it works
so
uh you don't have to post it this second
so what I'll have I'll work with Janet
to post something we can cancel it if we
need to but we'll see
yeah anything we do at this point like
says recess just in case you need to
call the committee back okay
but for example if you wanted to do what
you're discussing discussing the 10
million and then we'll tally it up and
if it works great if not you have to
revisit just like any every other
decision all three divisions have made
to this point we can do that at the end
of the week okay
so there's a motion been made to
transfer 10 million into Highway fund
yes
um yes along with that motion motion
search here I'm wearing if we should
also authorize the
to use
um up to 2.5 million each year to
to tick off items number 39 and 40 on
page three as they see fit
I would just clarify the motion to just
appropriate those dollars in their
budget as requested because otherwise
that would be a that's a whole nother
thing to do authorizing up to a certain
amount so if you want to if you want to
pick those numbers or if you want to
adjust them to a rounder number whatever
you want to do but those are the
requests that came in those would be in
house bill one what are the line numbers
again 39 and 40. thank you
so right totally marvelous
where are you taking the Surplus from
that's five minutes
this this proposal here would be a 20
from 23 Corporation
will be a transfer in 23 from the
general fund of the highway fund
general fund to the highway fund
so just using round numbers you'd move
10 million in you're going to authorize
spending of five of it and then if you
go back to page eight that would get
your ending Highway fund Surplus
somewhere around the 10 to 11 million
range
so right now we're just talking about
the 10 yes
any questions on the 10
all those in favor
so it's seven
one and one abstention one obvious one
absentee
now if you want to take any action on
the equipment
no just well we just authorized them
they can spend that real quick they
cannot so just a reminder the depart the
Department of Transportation is also
appropriation authority to spend money
so they don't have an open Highway fund
whenever they want to so you have to
authorize it correct technically you
would authorize this request and I would
increase their class 30 equipment buy an
amount however amount you pick and that
would give them Highway funds won't you
pick the
amounts okay give us four four million
786 foreign
okay
do you have a second
okay thank you
all those in favor
and that's
oh well I'm assuming
they wouldn't have requested it in their
exceptional needs that if the article
was found I'm assuming that soon yeah oh
we've got 56 million and to confirm that
was both lines 39 and 40. correct so
just using just round numbers that will
leave the highway fund and an ending
balance at the end of fiscal 25 around
10 or 11 million I'll shakeouts
somewhere in the I want the rounding
somewhere in there yeah I'll do the
exact amount
okay what else Mickey I got I got one
the uh that bail uh
for a million dollars uh make that
motion to uh
where does that go
yeah Department of Safety Department of
Safety Could you um could you help me
with the motion the the I'd say at this
point with the information we have if
this is something that the committee
wanted to move forward with we would
make a one million dollar appropriation
um
and I can charge it to whichever fiscal
year makes the most sense of as dust
settles here uh to the Department of
Safety for this purpose I don't know
what it is quite yet I'll work with the
department to get the language right to
get the intent of this I make that
motion
it's like a Knicks check
at the state level because if somebody
gets arrested let's say in Hampton
all right all right and then they could
drive up to Conway all right they get
arrested again this identifies that
they've got an arrest warrant or or
they've benefited they're out on bail
from the from Hampton
so you know that's this is this is a
probably a good idea because it I mean
yeah
is that clearance the software
yeah it's it's a Knicks check at the
state level
concept I just
member of the New Hampshire bar of
course I support
um you know better communication for our
law enforcement in order to you know
better enforce
you know folks who are out on bail
across the state of course that's a
wonderful idea and a goal we should be
working toward but uh I would say that
my approval is conditional upon seeing
the language about you know what it is
we're talking about you know is it in
fact do you have anything a piece of
software or is it in fact just the
concept that there will be you know
communication between state law
enforcement I mean what are we talking
about I think it's the question
organize the next local Nick system
I I haven't seen that from anybody else
so I I thank you I take your word but I
want to see what it is on paper I have I
have this memo that was dropped off
today and I can make copies of this this
was just given to me
hours ago maybe or two hours ago so I
can provide copies
uh if you want to give me why don't we
do that because it provides information
any detail is Right other than that
we're pretty much done
over building a I think building
and have we filled in all the white
blanks here
um did we do we decide about fish and
game I don't recall fishing game
science professional development here
that whole section that the governor
that's a 4.9 million
area
right but we don't need money
I mean 64.65
to do that job
Mr chair I think there's also an
important discussion to be had over the
education Freedom account allocation of
60 million I know that the Democratic
caucus in the house is really
uncomfortable with that
um I think this is an appropriate time
to
today would also be an appropriate time
to speak about that issue at length
well he's making copies would you like
to address that
um
I know that there are members of our
caucus who believe that this
increase to 60 million over the biennium
for the education Freedom accounts is a
non-starter item for voting for the
budget
um
you know we have Phil philosophical
differences of course between our
parties about you know
the purpose is an intent and you know
funding sources for this
um
I know that in addition to that just
general dollar amount that people object
to there's also great concern about
um the 10 overhead that's going to this
third party
that is making a profit from this as
well as um you know the the guard rails
on accountability for you know where
that money is going and safety concerns
as well that representative Heath has
brought up so I I know this is a
a very difficult subject for our caucus
and I think you know if you're intending
if your caucus is intending to push that
across the line I know that's going to
be very difficult just on that principle
Point alone so
my My Hope Is that we would be able to
you know reduce the overall allocation
for the two-year biennium and to
possibly consider putting that overflow
into school school building Aid which I
know is also a very difficult subject at
the moment but um you know I think
they're the
the moratorium has put so many districts
in line for that school building Aid
that they're really fighting for and
hoping for and um I think you know in
terms of benefiting kids across the
state
um that could be a wonderful opportunity
to compromise to try to find people on
both sides of the aisle to try to move
the ball forward so that would be my my
suggestion for an opening
uh discussion point
um I I have heard amounts floated I my
personal preference with the seat would
be to see not a single dollar go into
the educational Freedom account which I
know is a non-starter for your caucus so
um
um I've also heard
like a 10 million dollar reduction in
the overall funding per year to be
allocated
across to the building age so 20 total
reduction from the 60.
thank you
okay
it wasn't the motion it was just okay
we'll interrupt that discussion then
to take a moment to read this and see if
we can
take action or not
foreign
so where does the million come in here
because on here I'm looking at 181
million and I'm not sure what that's
going to and then it was probably not
going to have the thing on the back
about
some customers may not have internet
connection at all and what's needed to
develop this I'm not can someone connect
this with the million dollars page two
on the bottom
you got the whole thing thank you
potential legislative funding it's one
million
okay
oh there it is right here it's on the
back seat
breakdown
wow
well 50 000 maintenance
benefits
so this is currently a project for the
state of Illinois
so I'm like I'm like a page two
solution technology paragraph and it
talks about the spots configuration
which is a current system it sounds like
they basically need to
create a new query function
that would allow vendors
will the vendor would have to create
this interface so that it would allow
the information to transfer from the
agency to these spots
and seamless connection so it sounds
like an upgrade to the existing system
according to that paragraph
tier we don't really have an we have a
chair Weiler came in and explained this
sort of but we really don't have a
proposal from the Department or anything
I did do some really uncomfortable
funding a million dollars to something
that just it kind of came off the cuff
and we really don't know what it's about
I don't know I just I'm not comfortable
at all supporting this I'm sorry
yeah I'm trying to read this and I kind
of seconded I suspect that this is
understandable but again I have to
object that we're bringing stuff in at
the last minute we're supposed to be
finishing stuff and we've had several
new things come in and
why in the world this couldn't have been
part of the entire process I just don't
know I mean it just seems incredibly
disorganized and as I said process I
object to having things you know
placed in front of us
um without any anyone here to speak
about it
I mean it wasn't in the police
State Police presentation at any across
the
so I'm wondering I'm safe you didn't
bring it up yeah so that's my concern
now is like um
if this is a critical item it seems like
they would have built that into their
process
I think also they're not here to comment
on that right now so that also makes me
a little concerned I think the chair
was solicited by
criminal justice pure criminal justice
oh correct
criminal justice is not us
so or the money with the money
it is is this Appropriations in here for
440 million
what is that I think they're just
looking at the one million that's at the
bottom of page two
pointed out
but this isn't cut this is coming at the
last minute it's not coming from safety
and no one has explained what it is
this 440 million dollars in here is that
does that affect New Hampshire
one year to project total
has asked our stocks
can I can I ask Nikki a question
is there a mechanism for bringing this
in through fiscal or through some other
mechanism because I mean I'm really just
can't go there at this date without any
knowledge here
uh no safety has authority to come to
fiscal for Highway funds so
unless it was this that face value
doesn't look like it's an exclusive
Highway fund
uh item so I'm not sure they would have
the authority to do this through fiscal
um
and I don't have any other information
on this I did reach out to the
department and they didn't know
I don't think really what I was talking
about when I asked them about it so I'm
not sure that this has been presented to
them at this point they were going to
look into it and this was an hour ago so
I I haven't had a response yet
let me let me talk to the chair uh and
see if he wants to come say some
supporting words because this was his
deal so we'll reset it for five minutes
I can't even understand it
better than what it's this this says 440
million dollars no that's uh it's in
here I don't know right right here is
what you want to be reading this is
on this page uh back to page back page
backup
and trading there and in anticipation of
the separate Advanced State Police has
asked our Sports vendor along with
all RMS vendors to submit a quote
to show the load indicator attachment
One supplement support
New York State Police could not be
soliciting
over this aspect of services our current
spot Defender interface
see they they've already they already
have some
they already have some
some capability
you read this right here
yeah no I've read it you could take that
one I got one there okay
thank you Mr chairman uh this just came
to me as I was walking in here with my
other amendment I had a brief discussion
with chairman Roy
and it made a lot of sense that if
someone gets arrested bailed out
and then runs away and starts another
crime people the second group or the
third group that arrests him has no clue
that he's already been bailed
and obviously he's he's already
violated his bail conditions so that
would add further to his crime and he
should not be bailed again but that is
likely to happen and if we're going to
keep these criminals off the street that
continue to
um
break the law then this seemed like a
good thing for a million dollars they
have to go back to their providers of
their uh and their system and
put a million dollars up to get this
patch so that everybody then law
enforcement will know
by looking up who's been arrested who's
been bailed how did they get here
so I'm thinking this is worthy of a
million dollars and I think we have the
money now to put this million dollars
into a very useful program that will as
crime is getting rampant in the streets
we need to do something so I'm moving
that this should be adopted thank you
thank you Mr chair
um
the uh is this part of the Nyx system or
Nick's reporting which which identifies
so yeah it talks about the ncic unit
makes centralized crime data immediately
available to criminal justice agencies
and and the reason they're not
soliciting
a second or RFP is because they already
the system's already in place this is
just an addition yeah this is this is so
it'd be a little bit quicker
that it would get reported and available
question yeah thank you Mr chair thank
you Mr chair for taking my question so I
just want to be clear on this um that um
the chair of Criminal Justice
Terry Roy asked for this
um did he coordinate at all with the
safety
um does he know whether or not this
works has there been any background does
this department of safety want this
yeah that's that's what's the head
letter there it works as a second page
New Hampshire State Police
support's continued efforts in ensuring
all law enforcement in the field have
Reliable Tools
then they go on and on about that
the uh
Justice information Bureau I talk about
ncic
and spots
does not have a mechanism in place to
receive and or share with law
enforcement agency bail conditions on
any New Hampshire citizen in real time
or efficient capacity currently law
enforcement agencies need to contact the
issuing Agency on the courts directly to
obtain any bail condition information
this information may not be provided in
a timely manner resulting in the agency
foregoing the request prior to
interacting with any individuals the
inability for law enforcement agents to
ascertain agents to ascertain the
potential conditions of an individual's
bail condition can present a public
safety risk if the agent is not able to
ascertain any potential level of risk
and or violation that could be presented
during an interaction implementing these
updates will allow law enforcement
agencies to send and receive information
via spots thus contributing to our
continuous effort to provide an
Innovative accessible data exchange
platform that can benefit agencies and
reduce the risk to Public Safety but Mr
chair this has been from our new
Hampshire Department of Safety
nhsb is yeah no excuse me this is an RFP
request for proposal and it's put forth
by one network environment for justice
this is not coming from the Department
of Safety this is an RFP that these
people are these this is an organization
that's looking for money to do this but
I don't know anything that the
department of safety has said yes this
is a direction in which we want to go
and what's missing for me is the
Department of Safety saying we would
like to contract with these people
and this is an RFP from um I suppose a
pseudo private or public kind of a
company and I think it's really weird
that we would fund an RFP for an
organization that has not come to us and
said yes we actually would like this
I mean I can't I'm it's I just can't go
there sorry
I guess this came late to uh
to the criminal justice committee and
they thought well gee we're working on
the budget maybe we got time to put this
in so
as far as I knew from from
chairman Roy
this had been presented by the state
police or some police agency so this was
the paperwork that he had
which which kind of spelled it out so
yes
oh thank you Mr chairman I think
saying that that um this this tool would
be a wonderful benefit to the state if
enacted I think
um for me I do have two lingering
questions though about
um the program itself so one I'd like to
know how many arrests in the state of
New Hampshire happen after a bailout
violation so I'd like to know the like
what quantity of dual arrests are we
talking about is this a significant
problem in the state that warrants a
million dollar allocation the second
question I I'm asking just is being
familiar with a criminal justice system
and um the court system in the state of
New Hampshire is will an increased
reporting time from the moment of the
Dual arrest the second bail violation
arrest
um that point in time be sped out from
the court procedure time when a
magistrate
looks into the cork system and realizes
that this name is already existing on a
public Docket in a different part of our
state if that Delta in time just
speeding up that process of notification
to the second you know to the second
arrest in law enforcement body
if that makes a significant difference
and the increased safety of New
Hampshire
um
you know Granite Staters across our
communities so while I understand that
it of course is important for law
enforcement to understand that this is a
second violation as soon as possible I
know that that
piece of information comes to light in
the court system further down the road
my question is just by bumping up that
timeline does it actually make us safer
as a state to allocate another million
dollars
um to that effort and you know my my
and just hearing myself ask that
question out loud I realized
um I think it doesn't and the reason why
I say that is because the second
violation has already taken place and
that person is already in custody
um so I think if we're talking about
million dollar here a million dollars
there down the road
um across the important functions that
we are looking at
in the state that that million dollars
could be better served elsewhere I think
a good counter argument to that very
point would to be have the department of
safety here and putting it in their
process saying that this million dollars
is an important allocation but we're
missing that we're missing that key
ingredient and I again would just like
to say I think the process that we have
undergone up to this point has been
methodological or methodological for
every department and the mere Factor
that's coming to us late not from the
Department of Safety itself tells me
that this is not a priority of theirs
and that you know while this is an
interesting discussion for future
bienniums and you know I'd love to hear
the department of safety weigh on weigh
in on this I don't think this is where
the last million dollars we should be
determining goes today
I'll see if I can get the chairman here
to tell us what prompted this with him
and I'm sure he's had more experience
than the rest of us with how frequently
this occurs I'll see if I can find him
to to give us a little more data okay
we've got some other things to do all
right you've got other things to do but
I'll go on a hunt okay
now we'll jump back to
alternate discussion B
and so you we were talking about Freedom
accounts
that had you exhausted your I
interrupted you
yeah I think I think
I think um my
been exhausted I think that
I know for our caucus that uh you know
if everything else in the budget was a
nice compromise and everyone was feeling
good about it they still would be stuck
on this point
um
and I think that this is a good I think
you know
when all is said and done through the
process especially as we finish today
and move into you know Friday's final
determinations
you know I think a very positive message
to send to our to both sides of the
aisle who will be making these ultimate
determinations is that you know you
understand that our caucus is not
comfortable with the efas and that your
caucus wants to increase it by 100 of
the current funding level
and I I would say you know the way to
find a compromise
from those two you know eras the Deltas
to reduce it by 50 so that's where I
have heard this number circulating
um
for the the 20 million over the two
years so it's like 10. of each of the
biennium each Year's in the biennium to
reduce the funding funding increase and
use my suggestion is to use that Delta
and put it into school building age
which we understand has been another
important point of discussion for this
committee for several weeks so
that that was my suggestion in the
second half of the conversation
okay I would like to address one one
part and that is the 10 percent
I queried that to say that's a lot of
money
and what happens is the managing uh
entity of this of these funds
I'm trying to remember how many people I
think they said 12 they had 12 people
they have to account to the
for their time
to administer
anything that they don't cons that they
don't have billable time for
flows to the fund itself it's not like
they keep all 10 the 10 the 10 percent
is is a budgetary number
but they flow a lot more of the money
to
the program then
90 percent
that's what I was told on my employee
so
based on that
could we
I've been long concerned about the 10 I
think there was a factor built in it was
a startup cost the 10 percent
I'd be very comfortable if we could move
that down to seven percent
from the 10 percent
well this is amazing but on one hand
we've got all the details on the other
hand we we don't know all the details
yes chairman Roy on speaker can I put
him up so we can answer any questions
sure if you just hold the phone by the
mic
introduce yourself Jim go turn it on
Mike
criminal justice committee
representative 31.
what other questions we'd like chairman
Roy to answer
question
is
n't a safety requesting this request
yes
and then
um with that why didn't they include
that in their budget request to uh
division two
because
um during the course of my duties as
chairman of Criminal Justice I was
considering numerous bail reform bills
and as part of that I started
researching into the cause of some of
the problems with regards to bail
Commissioners bailing people out who are
already on bail
and it came to light that they have no
way of knowing if somebody is already on
bail
so we did the research and what we
determined is if someone is arrested in
one town it can take sometimes up to a
month for the paperwork to get to the
court and be processed if
the support system is entirely paper
driven
so there's no
Commissioners have no way of knowing
someone who they are about to bail is
already out on bail on another charge
so it's my belief that they didn't even
know themselves the scope of the problem
they had
until we did this research and
discovered it
further questions sir thank you Mr chair
so um representative or chairman Roy
this is representative hackenfelps I am
a member of the New Hampshire Bar
Association and it's my understanding
that once a arrest has been
uh made and uh
potential alleged criminal has been
booked that the electronic system in the
state the court system will make a note
of that name of that person
and then you know
when they are in front of a magistrate
or a judge or any sort of criminal
proceeding takes place the formal record
is then
um capable of seeing within the system
cross state whether or not there is
other pending litigation you know
against this against this person if
there are other charges in the system so
my question is if we're what is the
increased
safety mechanism for the state to have
that information earlier than the point
of the second arrest
then at the point that the court system
entry is made the second time so I'm not
sure that there is any value to the
safety in the state of New Hampshire
by having this information faster than
the court entry system that already
takes place and is in
you know part of the processes of the
court system
she's saying that
um
she doesn't think it's good it's still
breaking up
no I hear you fine all right she's
saying that is this a big Improvement in
the speed of how quick it would take she
feels that once it's gone into the
system they should be able to access it
quickly I think you need to tell her how
lengthy that time is for it to get to
the second arrest person
yeah so currently if someone is arrested
and booked and it gets to the court it
can take weeks to a month before it
consented into the corporate system so
that it shows up on someone's criminal
record
the system would allow someone this
feels primarily with the time period
from the arrest to they get to court so
it can take sometimes months before
someone gets in on an arraignment this
whole time someone's out on bail there's
no entry on their criminal record so
they're walking around no one knows they
are on bail except for them and perhaps
the one Department that bailed them the
rest of the state has no idea that this
person is on bail so a bail commissioner
cannot make an informed decision as to
whether or not to let someone go knowing
they're already unveiling another charge
so this is a huge Improvement I spoke to
the state police local police the chiefs
of Police Association this would be a
huge office of safety issue they know
when they when they're dealing with
someone this person's already on bail on
a charge
um it would be a big Improvement
also just if I could add we have a slew
of proposals for Bear reform because
people are claiming you know people are
being let out on bail and we need to
take this away from the bail
commissioners
and a lot of those bills would be
unnecessary because the bail
Commissioners are being blamed in the
the bail reform that was done years ago
it's being blamed and it's not
necessarily true because it's never been
tried the because nobody really knows if
anyone's on bail so a bail commissioner
and the system is being blamed even
though it's a Communications error
anything further
but chairman Roy
question
um The Proposal the memo that we get
detail is about 851
000 in funding but asks for one million
with chairman Roy be able to uh
illuminate the additional about 149 000
that is being requested that's not
broken down
I still wasn't clear on the question
the memo that we have breaks down costs
up to 851
000 but then they ask for a million in
funding is there any background on the
remaining 149 that are not documented
here
was where was the request for the 851
oh
okay that was that was another
attachment you gave me but I don't have
in front of me you know that's uh
yeah I gave you the back of the back
quotes
yeah these these were backup quotes okay
so overall it said 850 000 potential
legislative funding is a million do you
know what the reason is the difference
between the 850 and the million
they have three or four different
vendors that handle the software for
different police departments around the
state
and for them to be able to access this
new system they're going to put in place
they have to write software updates
so some of the money is for an update
yes some of the money is is for vendors
to update the various police departments
how they sink in to the state system
right now the the way we have it it
frankly needs the whole thing needs
updating but this is the the a quick fix
and it's really frankly cheap money
compared to what it would take to revamp
the whole system
does that answer your question yes and I
will State for the record that in my
experiences the finance director of the
town of Windham there were quite a few
frustrations between the police
department and the State Police in terms
of just the difficulty of occasionally
communicating so
you know I I have seen reports of those
type of you know glitches that made it
hard to communicate not on this
particular Topic in general yep
I
um just a question about if this was
such a great program how come it didn't
come through a normal procedure
did you hear that how come it didn't
come through normal procedure
uh once again because it was not known
at the time this was something that just
came up in the last 30 days as I
considered these bail reform bills and
we dug into the process and it was
realized because remember everybody's
operating in silos the state police have
their system the local police have their
systems and neither neither of them knew
that they weren't talking to each other
so when I asked them why are bail
Commissioners releasing people that are
already on bail it became apparent that
they didn't know people or already out
of bail
so the state police within their own
system know if they arrest somebody in
that person's on bail but they don't
know for example if Manchester police
arrested somebody and it goes vice versa
so neither side of them or or nobody in
the system realized the system wasn't
talking to each other until I dug into
it and made them explain why a bail
commissioner would possibly let somebody
out who's already on bail
so that's why I didn't come to the
regular system
yeah thank you
um yeah thanks for doing this through
the phone uh this is Kate Murray
um what again I I retained all the bail
bills once I realized that this was a
problem we had a slew of bail bills to
fix a system that Frank ly may not need
fixing once I realized this was the
problem I said we need to fix this
before we start passing bail reform
bills that frankly wouldn't do anything
if this system isn't working
good point yeah thank you for that can
you say what is one net environment for
justice or J-1 I mean what we're looking
at seems to be a proposal from a company
to do this
um and I'm still very uncomfortable that
I'm not hearing from the Department of
Safety uh so can you speak to who wrote
this memo
that memo came from um I believe it's
the head person who's in charge of the
state police system that maintains all
of these things the state police
maintains a repository system I believe
it's called spots and I'm not too far
ahead of you on knowing what all this
means because I had to dig into it
myself and it's very confusing but the
the state police as far as I understand
hold the repository and various vendors
work with them so that different
departments can access that repository
so I asked the state police this person
who wrote the memo to get me
the companies that would be involved in
what it would cost so that everyone
could access that system and that's why
you see these different companies
involved
yeah is does that pertain also because I
see there's something the computer
projects of Illinois quotation uh the
bail condition notification hot file
sent to Jennifer Hackett and this is you
know um
is 181 thousand why what is this telling
me
this this page who are they
she's looking at the spreadsheet and
asking why all those other people are
involved other than just computer CPI
computer projects of Illinois plus
computer square and so on there's
several there's three different figures
on here and then no there's more there's
six
um each one each one of those different
line items is a vendor who is
responsible for
um accessing or writing software that
allow other other departments to access
the the state police system
and if it would help I could probably
try and reach out to the person who
wrote that memo and see if I could get
her to get on a call with you would that
be helpful if I could see if I could
access her right now it would be helpful
to hear from the Department of Safety
again why don't you let me
let me reach out to her
she with all due respect we have a ton
of work today and I mean really visited
even a division two issue
yeah it is we have safety that's true
and State Police
right thank you do we have enough
information to vote
yes I do thank you Terry
office
into it
effort as well
thank you
thanks Terry
I think Mr chairman I I move the
question
okay
so I'll work with the Department of
Safety to clarify what this is for and
come up with something in House Bill too
to direct the funds for what its
intention is
so just to close out House Bill 2 if we
want to flip to
page two of the packet
I'll go through our blanks here and just
kind of update everyone as to where
we're at
so section 159 the suspension of RSA 99b
I think we can delete that section the
decisions made to this point you'll be
in compliance with that law so you won't
need that suspension
uh 164 section 164 and 167 this was
addressed earlier today with amendment
number 1105 representative Weiler's
Amendment on the education trust fund
uh 165 167 there's a placeholder there
those sections relative to the school
building Aid fund the 75 million that
was proposed the governors will just be
deleted so there'll be an amendment to
delete those
the section 170 the CTE renovation that
will be part of the 1105 amendment that
switches that over to the general fund
section 171
172 173
174 and 175.
will be part of
and also
177 will be part of a an adequacy
amendment that'll essentially be that
proposal 10 that we adopted earlier
today
which will also include
going back a ways now a repeal of the
extraordinary needs accountability plans
if you remember we talked about that so
that didn't come up today but I'm
tracking that as a tentative thing the
division was unanimously supportive so
that Amendment will include that
section 176 relative to Charter Schools
we adopted the amendment to bring their
total
base aid plus additional Grant up to
nine thousand the representative Mooney
Bill house bills 272.
Steve
from velax
um in that he is a charter school but
kind of exists in a alternate framework
um will he benefit from this because I I
told him I thought he would because the
base 4.7 went up
so
um he his payments are based on a
percentage of they divided by Caitlyn
knows by the number of courses
um but he would benefit he just doesn't
get the thousand dollars from
representative Mooney's Bill
the debate the representative Mooney's
build is not address velax right the
amount to base the cost of adequate
education is considered for vlax and
deal week and correct me if I'm wrong
thank you very much
and sections 210 to 11 relative to the
business profits and business Enterprise
tax allocations that was covered with
representative Weiler's bill as well or
excuse me Amendment 1105. so
my plan is to
update this as our final cumulative of
everything we've done to this point as
well as the next few pages the I'll
shade the things we approved today on
the additional requests I will update
page five which is the culmination of
all the budgetary changes the month the
money impacts that the division did as
well as your general or excuse me not
general education trust fund Highway
fund and Fish and Game Surplus
statements
two unrepresentative heck and Phillips
um request we had started conversation
about the efas and reducing the total
amount per um
per year of the biennium and then
changing removing those funds and adding
them to the building Aid is that
something that we could contemplate for
for this budget period please
for action and I don't know if
representative hacken Phillips wants to
say anything else to go with that
I think for as we talked about earlier I
think in terms of our selling
this budget to the caucus I think the
fact that we're increasing building Aid
by twenty thousand twenty million
dollars and reducing the efas by 20
million dollars would be significant it
would be taking it from 60 to 40 and I
we don't know we don't have a fiscal
note from the Department of Ed because
they've said that it's indeterminate
because they don't know who's going to
apply and um what category they'd be in
um so it looks like 40 million dollars
would be enough
um Caitlyn would you correct me if I'm
wrong
good afternoon
um you are corrected in the fact that
the department does not have any family
media and information so we can't do it
an estimate to determine how many
additional kids may become eligible
and Mr chair if in fact for some reason
the efas went over I believe that money
would be just drawn down from the trust
that is correct the department has the
ability to draw a warrant for any
additional funds needed for both or for
traditional adequacy district adequacy
and efas
thank you Caitlin did not say that
so I I believe let me explain how that
works so two things happening here one
for just everyone's General
understanding efas are similar to
Charters and adequacy in that it doesn't
matter how much money is in the
education trust fund those warrants are
drawn and those payments are paid
but as far as the EFA
appropriation that appropriation is
really a symbol of your estimate of what
you think the program would cost so
while the department does have the
authority to you could put zero in the
budget and not not account for it and
you just wouldn't be capturing what you
think
is going to be the actual cost of that
program and doe would still cut those
checks so really what you see in house
bill one for adequacy charter schools
and DFAS is really your budget
committee's estimate of what you think
those costs will be so if you are going
to set a new number for those you should
have a basis for why you're doing that
and
I don't have any guidance on that at
this point if you recall last biennium
there was also a budget committee
estimate and there's also other
estimates in the Surplus statement
relative to other programs that it's up
to the budget writers to say this is
what we think it's going to be and as of
right now there's been no change to the
29 million per year that has been put
forward by the department and then the
governor for the EFA program for 25 and
26. 24 and 25. so any change to that I
would just say uh
just know know all that
since the funding has to happen
regardless of what we budget I don't
think that cutting anything from the
funding accomplishes anything really
because the same amount will be spent
regardless of what amount we put in the
budget so to come back to the amount we
put on the budget it is the best
forecast we have right now in terms of
what we expect we expect the
expenditures to be and yeah those
forecasts have not been terribly
accurate in the past but you still have
to make a good faith effort to put the
you know correct number there so I would
suggest maybe decoupling the question of
what we put in the building aid from
what we take out of the Year phase
because I just
don't really see how
changing that EFA number does anything
then put us at risk of not saving money
for expenditures we may need and then we
will run into trouble with potentially
you know overrunning the budget so
um I've asked what was the basis for
coming up with the 30 million or guess
what is it yeah 30 million each year
what was it
um you know I propose what Mickey was
saying that these things are based on
some sort of a measure
what was the EXP what was that measure
we didn't get an answer from the
commissioner
um there seems to be you know whatever
principles involved we don't know so as
far as I can tell this this estimate is
just a guess and it's not based on
anything
true but it came from apartment event
went through the governor and then it
came to us so
my eyeballs have been looking at it well
then our estimate would be as valid as
theirs since it's both based on an
estimate of what we might imagine so
ours would be as valuable any estimate
at this point is as viable as this one
well do you want to make a motion
so
um
I should probably look at the right page
shoot where is the line item page seven
thank you
so I'm looking at page seven line item
my motion would be to reduce the
fiscal year 24 and 25 estimate for the
education Freedom accounts by 50 so that
it would Now read oh I'm sorry
um by 10 000 each a million sorry yes
that's been a long day
10 million each so that uh the line item
for 24 would Now read
19 million 852 000 uh and for 25 as well
um
and my proposal
is to net out that change and to
allocate that additional 10 million in
each year
for school building a new projects which
is line item 27.
second
all those in favor
all those opposed
motion tails
so we want to make that motion
chairman uh
make a motion to authorize the LBA to
make any Technical and mechanical
changes necessary to HB one and two in
order to reflect the intent of the
division
second call us in favor
so I think we're I believe we're done
nothing
so Fish and Game Surplus statement on
page nine will be how you see it there
there's no changes made to that
so at this point committee I will we did
a lot of stuff today so I'm going to
take all this back and update these
tracking sheets with all the Amendments
we've adopted with updates and the
columns as the decisions made the
dollars spent as well as the updated
Surplus statements for Education fish
and Highway I'm going to send those out
as soon as I can to this Division and
I'll put it online so everyone knows
what I've tracked as our changes please
review that if you see an egregious
error you know that you think wait a
minute I don't think we did that I'll
double check with the clerks file and
we'll see if we captured everything as
intended by the committee I would
suggest Mr chair we recess
only if necessary I'm gonna I'll have
Janet's schedule uh and post a meeting
for 10 o'clock on Friday uh sometime
between now and then you'll know the
division chairs will know if there's a
need to to gather again or Not by then
so I would keep it open on your
schedules but you know if it's
determined that it's not necessary then
we're good to go until next week
otherwise we'll get back Friday and take
up whatever things we need to take up
then
it's the quick logistical question when
do we expect to have an idea of whether
the 10m will be needed or not I mean I'm
keeping my schedule open but I'd like to
not have to keep it open until 9am on
Friday to hear about it I mean when
would be a reasonable time to expect to
know either way
so we based after everyone after the
three divisions wrap up today we'll pull
it all together we'll tabulate
everything and we'll provide to the
chair and the division chairs the
position that we see that all the
decisions are in then it'll be up to the
chairman to decide from there if it's
necessary or not we'll probably sometime
Wednesday or Thursday perhaps tomorrow
perhaps Thursday
I mean honestly feeds by Thursday it's
fine I just you know there is a certain
amount of uncertainty at the last moment
that's hard to do you know I'm not
worried about Thursday I already know
other questions or comments
okay so we will recess until Friday at
10.
or sooner potentially I mean I don't
think you're going to want to meet after
a session day but I would just say
you're in recess in recess there you go
perfect not into a specific time that's
all oh I got you I got you thank you
we're in recess
foreign